من القاهره الكاتب ايمن سلامه اهلا بك سيد
ايمن معنا في مساء العربيه رمضان كريم
رمضان كريم واهلا وسهلا بكم وبكل مشاهدي
قناه العربيه طيب نبدا بمسلسل جميله يركز
على فكره التمكين المراه في المناصب
الكبيره بالدوله كيف تناولتم ذلك دراميا
[موسيقى]
حاولت ان انا اقدم شكل جديد للمراه
المصريه في ظل
تمكينها من
وجودها في منصه القضاء وجودها في مناصب
حساسه في الاونه الاخيره فحاولت ان انا
اقدم الشخصيه دي بما يخدم الدراما بتاعتي
ان هي شخصيه عادله شخصيه حازمه شخصيه تحب
الحق شخصيه فارسه ولكن هل هتنتصر على
مجموعه المتغيرات اللي حصلت في المجتمعات
العربيه والمجتمع المصري في الاونه
الاخيره هل هتستطيع ان هي تواجه
النفوس الشريره الموجوده هنشوف ده بقى من
خلال الحلقات الاخيره في المسلسل طيب يا
استاذ ايمن يعني كل ها الصفات هي ليست بال
بتكون جميله يعني بهاي الحاله فما دلاله
اختيار اسم جميله للمسلسل
[موسيقى]
اسمي جميله هو
يعني اسم الشخصيه تمام وهي ان هي جميله
النفس يعني هي جميله النفس جميله الشكل
والنفس فهي شخصيه جميله اتحطت في وسط
مجموعه من القباحه مجموعه من القبح فكيف
هل هل يستطيع الجمال ان ينتصر على القبح
ام ان القبح في هذا الزمن سينتصر هو ده
السؤال او اللغز اللي احنا بنشوفه في
المسلسل طيب او كيف ناقش كذلك المسلسل
العديد من القضايا الخاصه بالاسره مثل
عقوق الاباء
[موسيقى]
وناقش قضيه اهم وهي قضيه ان الاب او الام
ممكن يتسببوا في ضرر اولادهم اذا كان يعني
الانسان يكتب سلوكه يكتب تاريخه فلو ان ما
اخدش باله من سلوكه ممكن يؤثر ذلك على
اولاده فدي شخصيه رئيسه نيابه وشخصيه
مرموقه في المجتمع ولابد ان ما يكونش
عليها اي ملاحظات فلما الام تكون تعمل اي
عمل لابد ان هي تنتبه جيدا لما تفعله لان
ممكن يؤثر ذلك على وظيفه بنتها ممكن
يفقدها وظيفتها ممكن يؤثر على مستقبلها
المهني في حاجه هي بتحبها في جزء اخر كمان
المسلسل بيناقشه هيظهر فيما بعد وهو جزء
علمي اللي هو فكره الحقن المجهري وممكن
يحصل فيه ايه واسبابه يعني في مناقشه كده
هتظهر في الحلقات القادمه ديت طيب يا
استاذ ايمن طالما احنا يعني الحلقات اللي
لهلا حضرناها عم نحكي
فبالتالي لما بنحكي على مسلسل جميله اللي
هو دراما يحارب الفساد ضمن اطار اجتماعي
هل برايك انه نجحت ونجحت الدراما في
مواجهه الفساد
الدراما بتغير المجتمعات احنا كمجتمع عربي
كل تسليتنا وثقافتنا بناخدها من التلفزيون
او من دلوقتي من المنصات
فاحنا محتاجين جرعه دراما قويه والدراما
اخطر ما في الدراما ان هي بتدخل في السلوك
البشري بتدخل في لا شعور الانسان فبتاثر
في السلوك بتاعه
فانت بدون ما تعي انت بتتاثر بالافلام
والمسلسلات اللي انت بتتفرج عليها فبعد
فتره بتلاقي سلوكك نتيجه جماع هذه الافكار
بيدخل في
الشعور بتاعك وبيتحكم فيك وبيخليك تفعل
اشياء او تكون ثقافه مختلفه
عن اللي كانت موجوده عنك فاحنا بصدد ان
التقديم الدراما ان الدراما فعلا زي ما
بقول لك
جانب ان هي نوع من الترفيه هي نوع من
الثقافه نوع من مناقشه القضايا والمشاكل
اللي موجوده في المجتمع العربي
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على ظهورك وجودك
معنا يا استاذ ايمن سلامه الكاتب من
القاهره شكرا جزيلا لك